This video was made possible by CuriosityStream.
Sign up for any subscription at CuriosityStream.com/Wendover
and get free access to Nebula, where you can
watch my new trivia show, or our upcoming
Wendover original.
Back during World War Two, a young doctor
named R Adams Cowley spent his deployment
on the battlefields of Europe, treating patients
on the precipice between life and death.
He observed, through this experience, that
those suffering the medical state of “shock”
following a traumatic injury were placed on
an often certain, but not immediate, path
towards death.
This exposure to those patients developed
his life’s goal: he sought to take those
on that certain path towards death, and nurse
them back to life.
He wanted to be able to treat then-untreatable
major traumatic injuries.
Some years later, in 1960, he neared closer
to this goal by opening, in some corner of
the sprawling University of Maryland Medical
Center, a two-bed unit dedicated to treating
major trauma patients—the first such department
in the country.
Cowley started with about a 40% survival rate,
but as his experience accumulated, and his
techniques refined, more and more patients
survived.
It turned out that the certain path towards
death for major trauma patients was not so
certain.
However, he also observed that even his reliable
techniques couldn’t reverse the course of
death if a patient took too long to get to
him.
He posited that once someone experienced major
trauma, they had a roughly 60-minute window
to reach him, or else it was too late.
The problem was that, by the time other doctors
transferred a patient to Cowley, that window
had often passed.
The system just wasn’t suited for this sort
of speed.
Therefore, he reinvented the system.
First, he lobbied for ambulances to bring
trauma patients directly to him—or, eventually,
other trauma units—rather than just to the
nearest, potentially unequipped hospital,
as was standard protocol at the time.
Second, he convinced the Maryland State Police
to use their helicopters to bring trauma patients
to his unit—dramatically reducing the average
time to care.
Cowley dubbed this 60-minute window the Golden
Hour and the principles behind it are now
the central, guiding light of the Emergency
Medical Service system—its purpose is to
stabilize, triage, and transport as fast as
possible because, according to this Golden
Hour principle, faster is always better in
trauma medicine.
The vast majority of the American population
can reach their nearest hospital within the
Golden Hour with a traditional, ground-based
ambulance system, but not all.
This is a map of the US, and these are the
areas more than a sixty-minute round-trip
drive to the nearest hospital.
There are vast swaths of the sparsely-populated
American west where ground ambulances cannot
fulfill the golden hour principle, especially
given the recent spate of closures of unprofitable
rural hospitals.
In fact, it’s not even very difficult to
run into this problem.
If you were to drive from Denver to Las Vegas—two
major American cities—most of your trip
would take place on Interstate 70, which would
lead you through the desolate area of the
San Rafael Swell.
If your car were to crash here, your nearest
hospital would be over ninety minutes away
in Moab, and this is just on the interstate—the
central circulatory system of the US.
It’s plenty possible to get much, much further
from medical care and so, to plug these gaps,
to get patients in the most rural areas and
dire circumstances to care as fast as possible,
that’s where the country’s air ambulance
system steps in.
Across the nation, there are some 900 air
ambulances stationed at hundreds of bases,
each of which expands the number of people
able to reach hospital within an hour.
Each of these aircraft have the potential
to change lives each and every day, and play
a big part in many people’s worst days.
When your life is on the line, every minute
counts, so these aircraft save life and limb
with every flight… right?
Well, to a certain person, maybe an executive
at an air ambulance company, for example,
the 702 words up until now probably all sound
correct, but are they really?
Everything up until now covered one simple
principle: more trauma patients brought to
the hospital within sixty minutes equals more
lives saved?
It can’t possibly be that the central tenant
of emergency medicine, the Golden Hour principle,
is just… wrong… right?
Well, in 2001, an academic review posed that
exact question and found, “no large, well-controlled
studies in the civilian population that either
strongly support or refute the idea that faster
is universally better in trauma care.”
Essentially, it said that the Golden Hour
principle could be true, but despite the fact
that the entire EMS system operates on the
collective assumption that it is true, we
just didn’t know for sure.
So, in response, researchers sought an answer.
Plenty found that the answer was yes—as
one would expect, faster transport to the
hospital does improve survival outcomes—but
plenty others… didn’t.
This one found that, “the time factor involved
in managing and transporting hypotensive penetrating
injury victims directly to a regional trauma
center does not appear to be related to an
adverse outcome.”
This one concluded with, “no prehospital
time less than 90 minutes exerted a significant
adverse effect upon survival,” while this
one found, “no significant difference in
survival after traumatic injury when the 8
minute ambulance response time criteria was
exceeded.”
Similar results, failing to find a statistically
significant link between total pre-hospital
time and survival outcomes, were found in
this study, and this one, and this one, and
this one, and countless more.
Twenty years onwards from that academic review,
the only certainty here is uncertainty: there
is no scientific consensus on whether the
Golden Hour is truly relevant today.
Uncertainty is fine—it’s part of the scientific
process—but the entire American air ambulance
industry is built on a collective, unverified
assumption that the Golden Hour principle
is indeed true.
However, since we’re dealing with assumptions,
let’s tackle another one.
When you think of air ambulances, you probably
imagine a flight from here to here: scene
to hospital.
Of course, that’s what you see in the movies,
but these sorts of flights only account for
about a third of air ambulance trips.
The vast majority of their business involves
hospital to hospital transfers.
You see, the trauma care system that Doctor
Cowley innovated evolved into a nationwide,
hierarchical network.
Essentially, there are five levels of trauma
centers—hospitals certified to treat patients
with major traumatic injuries—and as you
go up in the levels, the centers become more
advanced, and less widespread.
Levels V and IV mainly deal with stabilization
and initial evaluation prior to transport
to a higher level center, while Level III
centers will have on-call surgeons who could
start to resolve simpler trauma cases.
Level II centers have surgeons with 24-hour
immediate availability, rather than just on-call,
in addition to certain specialists.
Then, those most advanced, Level I centers
have everything conceivably necessary for
any trauma case including specialists across
all fields, and the ability to treat a case
all the way from initial presentation through
rehabilitation—which can be a multi-year
process.
Level I trauma centers are incredibly expensive
to run, and therefore need a critical mass
of patients to cover costs.
Consequently, it’s very possible to be more
than 600 miles or 950 kilometers from one
while in the lower 48, or 2,000 miles or 3,200
kilometers from one while in Alaska.
Due to this potential distance, a major trauma
case outside a major city would typically
go first to a Level III, IV, or V trauma center,
which are far more commonplace, where they’d
be stabilized and evaluated to determine whether
they need to be transferred to a more advanced
facility.
So, someone in a vehicle crash in the San
Rafael Swell on I-70 in Utah would likely
first go to the Moab Regional Hospital, which
is a Level IV center.
If the doctors and nurses there determined
the patient needed a higher level of care,
they would be transferred—in this case to
St. Mary’s Hospital in Grand Junction, Colorado,
which is a Level II center.
Then, if that hospital determined the patient
had such complex and specialized injuries
that even they couldn’t handle it, the patient
would likely be transferred to Denver Health’s
Level I trauma center.
Since each of these transfers would take hours
by ground, the decision would almost certainly
be made, for major trauma cases, to use an
air ambulance.
This is the bread and butter of the air ambulance
business and surely this saves lives, right?
Well, yes and no.
In one study of major trauma patients suffering
from certain high-mortality injuries, patients
admitted to Level II centers had a 29.7% mortality
rate, while those admitted to a Level I center
only died 25.4 % of the time.
More advanced trauma centers do save more
lives, and therefore conventional wisdom would
assume that transfers to higher level centers
save lives, but conventional wisdom almost
always misses the nuance of a situation.
According to another study, some quarter of
adults and half of children transferred to
Level I trauma centers are brought there unnecessarily—in
other words, they’ve been subject to “secondary
overtriage” where the more advanced center
ends up discharging them after completing
treatment that a less advanced center would
have been plenty capable of.
Now, a certain level of secondary overtriage
is to be expected and even encouraged—after
all, it’s better to be safe than sorry—but
again, we need that nuance.
For an overtriaged patient, they would have
survived if they had stayed in a Level III
center, for example, and they did survive
when they ended up in a Level I center, so
the health outcome was the same, but for those
patients transferred by an air ambulance,
they received something else: an absolutely
massive bill.
A conservative estimate puts the average price
of an air ambulance flight in the US at $27,900.
Others put that figure even higher, well into
the 30 or 40 thousands, meaning it’s very
possible and even common for someone to be
charged more for a quick helicopter ride to
or from the hospital than they make in a year.
Another counterargument, though: a human life,
to the holder of that life, is essentially
invaluable—any cost to save it is worth
it—but the problem is not the cost, it’s
the price.
The cost for air ambulance companies to operate
a given flight, according to the companies
themselves, is somewhere between $6,000 and
$13,000.
That shouldn’t be possible—as in, quite
literally, the rules of economics say that
that gap between cost and price shouldn’t
be possible, because in a normal free market,
for normal products, competition would drive
down prices far closer to costs since lower
prices increase demand, and companies can
increase profits with greater market share,
but the American air ambulance market is very
far from normal.
Every product in the world can be mapped onto
a graph that looks like this: price on the
y axis, quantity purchased on the x.
This is what a normal product looks like—as
price goes down, quantity purchased goes up.
There are some exceptions to this—for example,
certainly luxury goods plot like this on the
graph, where higher prices actually stimulate
higher demand, to an extent—although almost
no product will look like this.
This, however, is the relationship between
price and demand for air ambulances—as price
increases, it has zero impact on demand.
It’s easy to understand why: the people
purchasing and paying for air ambulance flights
have no agency over whether or not to do so.
The decision to use an air ambulance is made
by first responders or doctors, not the often-unconscious
patient, and so there is a complete lack of
market forces working to lower the price.
When the free market isn’t working to regulate
the allocation of goods and services into
the most societally advantageous configuration—which
is this case would be the greatest possible
availability of air ambulances at the lowest
possible prices—economists would describe
that as a market failure.
In cases of market failure, even the most
staunchly libertarian economist would tend
to agree that the only solution, at that point,
would be external intervention—typically,
by the government—and so this massive, critical
industry charging vulnerable people massive,
crippling prices can’t possibly be completely
unregulated, right?
Wrong: in fact, not only is the air ambulance
industry not regulated, but it seemingly can’t
be.
You see, back in 1978, Congress passed the
Airline Deregulation Act, ending the government’s
ability to regulate the fares of airlines.
This led to a dramatic decrease in airfares
and a dramatic increase in flights—essentially,
it paved the way for the US to become the
world’s largest aviation market—but when
it sought to deregulate airlines, that truly
meant all airlines.
Through the years, as various states have
attempted to fix the market failure of the
air ambulance industry, providers have successfully
argued in court time and time again that because
they are technically airlines, and because
the Airline Deregulation Act prevents states
from regulating airfares, states therefore
cannot regulate the prices air ambulances
charge.
There is truly no limit to what they can charge.
But, wait.
There is another, unique market force in the
American healthcare industry that could solve
this problem: that of insurance, right?
You see, most insurers in the US have a network
of providers that they cover and, if a patient
uses an out-of-network provider, they are
charged a far higher rate, or are subject
to an annual spending cap.
In non-emergency circumstances, it’s often
possible to find an in-network provider, and
many states and recently the federal government
too have passed legislation limiting out-of-network
bills for emergencies, but of course, thanks
to the Airline Deregulation Act, those don’t
apply to air ambulances.
In the US, some 77% of air ambulance flights
are billed out-of-network, meaning patients
are on the hook for all, or at least the vast
majority, of those thirty or forty or fifty
thousand dollar air ambulance bills.
This is, once again, a symptom of market failure.
For most medical services, insured patients
have the ability to chose which provider they
go to, they have the ability to chose to go
to an in-network provider, which is a market
force that pushes providers to accept as many
types of insurance as possible—if they didn’t,
they would lose business—and those insurers
have the scale to negotiate prices down.
With air ambulances, though, since patients
have zero ability to chose which provider
they use, or even whether they use one at
all, there are no market forces pushing providers
to bring more insurers in-network.
In fact, they often get paid more from out-of-network
patients, meaning they they not only lack
incentive to bring insurers in-network, but
market forces are pushing them to minimize
the number of carriers in their network.
Air ambulance providers and, more specifically,
the private equity firms that now own the
majority of them, have figured out just how
exploitable this market failure is.
Since 2000, the number of air ambulances in
the US has more than doubled to nearly 900,
and the average annual flight hours per helicopter
have dropped from a high of 600 in 2003 to
almost 450, as these companies further saturate
the market.
In the same time period, average prices have
more than tripled.
It’s tough to get a good gauge of just how
much these companies are profiting on the
plight of Americans in the most vulnerable
moments of their lives, largely because almost
all the major players in the industry are
are now owned by private-equity firms, and
therefore don’t report their financial results.
What’s clear, though, is this: in 2017,
according to one study, air ambulances owned
by private-equity firms charged about double
of what those owned by hospitals or non-profits
did.
The costs to operate non-profit and for-profit
air ambulances are not dramatically different,
so the only reasonable conclusion is that
these private, for-profit air ambulances are
pocketing thousands upon thousands of dollars
in profit per patient.
There is nothing stopping this industry from
charging higher and higher rates—not market
forces, not regulation, nothing—and so these
private equity companies, having realized
this, will keep jacking up prices and turning
highway accidents and heart attacks into higher
returns for their investors.
Right now, this is an industry that can’t
be stopped.
There is, however, potentially momentum for
reform with the recently-passed No Surprises
Act, which caps out-of-network charges in
emergencies, but it’s unclear exactly how
this can and will impact the air ambulance
industry when it takes effect in 2022 given
the protections of the Airline Deregulation
Act.
Any doctor knows the words “primum non nocere”—a
latin phrase that translates to, “first,
do no harm.”
It’s a maxim that guides every med-school
bioethics course, and it essentially recognizes
that in medicine, it is possible to do more
harm than good.
It’s why, when someone reaches the final
days or hours of their life, and the outcome
is certain, the decision is typically made
to withhold treatment, because it can only
harm.
Treatments come with physical, emotional,
and financial burdens, so they’re simply
not worth it when the path towards death is
irreversible.
When air ambulances are used, the goal is
to reverse that path, and in many cases they
do.
However, the best research into the matter
estimates that for every 100 air ambulance
flights, four lives are saved.
That means that in 96 cases out of 100, the
patient or their next-of-kin walks out of
the hospital having lost a year of income.
They walk out having pushed back retirement
by a year, having lost the ability to send
their kids to college, or buy a house, or
go on vacation—they’ve lost a non-trivial
quantity of quality of life.
In 96 cases out of 100, doctors using private
air ambulance providers are forced to violate
their hippocratic oath, they are forced to
make a split-second decision that does harm
and changes lives for the worse, all because,
at the end of the line, there’s some wealthy
investor in some private equity firm who prefers
a 10.5% return on investment over 10.4%, and
nobody’s doing anything to stop them.
Any long-time Wendover viewer will have heard
of the CuriosityStream/Nebula bundle deal—you
sign up for any CuriosityStream subscription
at this link, and you get a free Nebula account
too—but for those of you who have not yet
signed up, now’s a really good time.
That's because I just released a three-part
trivia show featuring Brian from Real Engineering,
Jordan Harrod, and Dave from City Beautiful,
plus I’m releasing a brand-new Wendover
original that was shot a while ago on-location
next month.
Plus, CuriosityStream has a ton of great new
stuff too, like Dream Routes—a three-part
film that focuses in on three of Asia’s
most storied and historic roads, which really
helps scratch any travel itch you might have
right now.
On top of that, an annual CuriosityStream
subscription is 26% off right now, meaning
a year of two great streaming sites combined
is about the same cost of one fancy burger.
So, if you want to watch all Wendover and
HAI videos early and ad free, plus all our
exclusive originals, plus all of CuriosityStream’s
great non-fiction shows and films, make sure
to head over to CuriosityStream.com/Wendover,
and you’ll be helping to support this and
tons of other independent educational creators
while you’re at it.